Well what is the cos θ for example? Well, it's adjacent over hypotenuse.
But the hypotenuse is just 1. So X/Xmax is just equal to the cos θ.
Similar thinking tells us that V/Vmax is equal to the sin θ.
Now these two equations can be slightly rearranged to be written like this.
Okay, so we've learned that we can express position in velocity in terms of the
maximum position in velocity and some trigonometric function of this weird angle θ.
Theta only shows up on this strange diagram I've drawn.
It seems like it might somehow correspond to time
since you know that as time progressed I moved along this diagram.
But before we can move any further, let's talk about radians.